We talk about phenomenology last time
and
I tried to make the case that
phenomenology,
at least in part,
was an attempt to include
the entire domain of subjective
experience inside the definition of
reality.
Yeah.
When Roger's talked about mental health,
he was speaking of something that that
superseded just rational coherence.
Rogers also touched on
a topic that's become very well
developed since the time of Rogers,
which is the topic of embodied
cognition.
It's become increasingly clear
to artificial intelligence researchers
particularly
that
the enlightenment idea of rationality as
like a disembodied sort of spiritual
function is,
is wrong in principle.
And I think that's because
the way the brain sets itself up
with the body is the way that we
discussed when we were talking about
piaget.
It's that the mind is built from motor
actions up and the concepts that the
mind uses aren't abstract categories
that describe reality.
They're more like tools that allow us to
do things in the world.
And so they're predicated,
their validity is predicated on the fact
that we have a body.
And one of the things that Rogers was
trying to emphasize,
and I think there's a long history of
this in
in
western thought over the last few
thousand years,
that there's,
there are faculties of,
of apprehension that are higher than
rationality and some of those are
embodied.
So
it's a variant in Floridian theory
because the Friday ends of course
thought that it was necessary to attend
to emotions and motivational states and
to integrate them with the ego.
But it takes that idea further in some
sense
by treating the inputs of the body.
So motivational states and emotions,
but also perhaps the capacity to mirror
other people as a prerequisite for
mental health.
And so the other thing that Rogers
emphasizes
is to pay attention to how it is that
your experiential field is manifesting
itself while you speak and interact with
other people.
And he was hoping and pr and striving
towards a kind of unification.
It was analogous to the unification that
are described to you that young talked
about in his last book
there.
There's another practical element to
this that I should tell you that that I
think is unbelievably useful.
We talked last time a little bit about
the necessity of listening to people and
techniques that you could use to do that
in the effort to improve your
communications and and,
and also to improve the degree to which
you were gathering information that was
practically useful to you and
corrective.
But with the Rogerian techniques to some
degree,
you could do the same thing with regards
to the relationship between your
intellectual rationality,
which is sort of your knowledge as
represented at the highest level of
verbal abstraction and the platform on
which that knowledge is hypothetically
implemented.
So you can imagine in the [inaudible]
mode of development,
you start to learn how to move and then
those movements are chained in evermore
complex sequences and those sequences
start to become representable abstractly
so that you can describe yourself,
for example,
as a good person.
And hypothetically as you decompose the
idea of good person down towards
specific actions,
that whole hierarchy is internally
consistent in that you're a good person
in your self representation,
but you also enact all the things that a
good person would enact.
And then there's no flaws in the entire
hierarchy.
But the weird thing about having an
intelligence that's dissociable,
which means that you can think up things
without acting them out,
is that you can also formulate self
representations in ideas that aren't
fully integrated with the manner in
which you actually act.
So you can have a concept of yourself
and,
and even an ideological framework that's
only vaguely related to your,
to the programming that's been
instantiated in your body.
And Rogers would consider that,
uh,
he has a technical term for it.
It's a,
well it's a form of internal disharmony,
non congruent.
That's,
that's,
that's his term and the non congruent
ideas.
A very interesting one because in my
experience you can feel it.
So,
and here's something that you could try
as an experiment.
And I think it's as effective and
experiment as the listening experiment
that we discussed last time.
So
it's very common for modern people,
especially intelligent,
modern people,
to identify themselves with the contents
of their intellect.
But that's a strange thing to do in many
sense in many ways because first of all,
obviously you're not just the content of
your intellect,
your also your emotions and your
motivations and your body and so forth
and your embeddedness within a social
context.
But especially if you're intelligent,
it's tempting to identify yourself with
the contents of your intellect.
But there's no reason to assume
whatsoever that those contents are in
fact congruent with the programming of
your body or,
or even with its natural inclinations.
And that's partly because the fact that
you can abstract also means that you can
learn abstract.
And that means you can pull in concepts
from the world at a level of abstraction
that may have virtually nothing to do
with you.
And that's certainly the case if you're
educated because you read all sorts of
things and the,
you know,
the reading and all the investigating
that you do at an abstract level allows
you to have theories about being in
theories about yourself.
But there's no necessity that those
theories about being in yourself have
any basis in who or what you actually
are.
And so that can,
that makes you into the inauthentic.
That's the existential perspective and
the Rogerian perspective would be
incongruent.
There are,
you're not a singular entity at all the
multiple levels at which you exist and
that can cause conflict.
So for example,
maybe you're acting out in ideology
because you're convinced of its rational
integrity and coherence and utility,
but that utility,
that ideology doesn't fulfill you as a
individual.
That's certainly an existential claim.
It's a fundamental existential claim.
In fact,
as we'll talk about in in the next
lecture,
there are thinkers like soldier Nansen
who've ascribed the worst catastrophes
of the 20th century to exactly that kind
of inauthenticity,
which is the development of a coherent
and rational ideology,
say like a Communist ideology.
And then the attempt to force that on
the world and and on people,
despite the fact that the rational
formulation and the reality of the
people in the world have very little in
common.
Now,
how would you detect your own
inauthenticity or your,
your own incongruent?
Well,
Rogers had this idea that he called
subception which was maybe something
that you might regard as a sixth sense.
It's sort of like a proprietors centric
perception and that's the perception
that you have of your body as it's
reacting and localized in time and
space.
And so it's sort of like touch the
feeling but it's,
it's,
it's your sense of how you're reacting
internally and where you are.
And a lot of that is subserved by the
autonomic nervous system,
which is reporting to you about various
states of being in your body.
Rogers believed that you could use the
information that's being provided to you
from your body,
sort of bottom up to determine when you
were being inauthentic or non congruent.
And I've thought about this for a long
time and tried to sort it out in a
practical manner.
And what I've concluded is this,
you could try this for a couple of
weeks.
It's an extremely interesting exercise.
So you sorta have to detach yourself
from your thoughts and your and what you
say.
So you got to assume,
you start by assuming that what you say
and what you think is not necessarily
you,
and of course that's just the case
because a lot of what you think,
in fact,
most of what you think and most of what
you say are the opinions of other
people.
There are things you've read or things
people have told you.
You know that that's a benefit in some
ways because you get all those thoughts
that other people have spent a long time
formulating,
but it's a disadvantage in that it's not
exactly you.
Okay,
so you detach yourself from that.
You're no longer your thoughts or or,
or the things that you say or maybe
you're no longer all of them and now
what you're going to try to find out is
which of your thoughts and things that
you say are you and maybe so you not
utilize the rest or maybe so that you
can correct the rest because they're not
representative of yourself as a,
as an integrated being.
They don't take everything into account.
My sense has been that you can tell when
you're saying something that's not
authentic by feeling out whether or not
it makes you weak or strong.
Now you know what?
Sometimes when you're conversing with
people,
you can say something that embarrasses
yourself.
Now Nisha said,
for example,
everyone has perjured themselves at
least once in the attempt to maintain
their good name,
something like that.
It's not an exact quote,
but I've got the gist of it,
right?
So maybe you're saying things to impress
someone or you're saying things to
remain part of your political group or
your social group or whatever.
Or maybe you have attributes,
personal attributes that might be
positive that you're ashamed of and so
you're not going to speak about them.
So there's a falseness about yourself,
representation,
watch for two weeks and see,
make a rule that if you start to say
something and it makes you feel weak,
it's hard to describe exactly what that
means to me.
What it means is that I can feel things
coming apart sort of in my mid section.
So I think it's an autonomic phenomena
and the subjective senses of false hood.
It's like I've just stepped off to solid
ground and onto something that doesn't
support me well,
and it,
it feels like a self betrayal.
So that's existential inauthenticity.
You can feel it right away and then the
rule is shut up.
If that happens,
stop talking and then feel around and
see if you can find some words that you
say in that situation that don't produce
that sensation.
And it's like,
you see this played out in different
forms of drama.
So there's,
there's a scene in the Lord of the
rings,
for example,
where I believe it's Gollum and Bilbo,
it's the Lord of the rings.
It's,
yeah,
it's bill boats,
Lord of the rings,
not the hobbit because the hobbits
Frodo,
right?
So it's Bilbo there.
I've got it wrong.
So the other way around,
okay,
so gollum and Frodo,
yes,
are going across the swamp and the swamp
is full of essentially full of dead
Saul's.
And they have to step very carefully in
order to not fall off the track.
And the stones are sort of hidden
underneath the surface.
And the implication there is that in
order to follow a trail property,
you have to pick your,
your ground very carefully and you have
to test it to see if it's solid or
you'll slip off into this.
Well essentially what it is is chaos.
You'll slip off into chaos.
And that's a dramatic representation of
what I'm,
what I'm suggesting to you,
it's like all you have to do is notice,
but,
and you have to pay attention.
And so,
so to some degree what you're doing in
fact is you're making your capacity to
pay attention,
super ordinate to your capacity to think
and to speak.
Cause you,
you know,
you might ask yourself while exactly
what are you,
while I said you can identify yourself
with your intellect and that's very,
very common.
It's sort of like the worst sin of
intelligent people,
but that isn't all you are.
And there are lots of reasons for making
the assumption that attention is a
higher order function than intellect.
Because attention is what teaches
intellect.
So if by,
if you pay very,
very careful attention to what you say
without having the automatic,
without bringing the automatic
assumption that what you say is you to
bear on the conversation and then also
to feel like you have to defend it.
Once you say it,
you'll find very rapidly that very much
of what you think can say has absolutely
nothing to do with you.
It's just,
it's the dead souls that are in that
little scene that I described to you,
sort of manifesting themselves in your
head.
They're dead ideas that other people
have created and some of them might be
applicable to you.
You know,
you might have the right to them so to
speak,
but lots of the malt and you're using
the words as camouflage or self defense
or as an attempt to attain status and
the status hierarchy or to make yourself
look smarter than you are.
Or there's all sorts of reasons or,
or to hide what you think from other
people.
I see this and undergraduate essays all
the time.
So cause the essays are full of cliches
and you know,
it's not all that obvious.
Why a cliche is a bad thing,
but it cliche is a bad thing.
In the same way that being possessed by
the dead is a bad thing.
It's like a cliche isn't you?
It's something else.
It's like the crowd.
It's like the other,
it's,
it's not living.
It has nothing to do with you.
And part of the reason that students use
cliches is because it's easier than
using your own genuine creative
formulation.
So you can just default to cliche use.
But there's something more insidious
than that is that if you write an essay
that's nothing but a string of cliches
and you get criticized,
then you're not being criticized.
What's being criticized is the cliches.
And you can hide behind that and the the
part of you that's wise.
But,
but,
but treacherous thinks,
well,
the criticism doesn't really apply to me
because,
you know,
I didn't really say what I thought.
And then there's this kind of sense,
you get that you've gotten away with
something,
which is a terrible thing.
So when I read undergraduate essays,
what I see very frequently is,
especially the first essay,
it's just nothing but cliches.
It's awful.
It's,
it's dull.
You can hardly stand reading it because
there's nothing in it that's gripping or
alive.
And then maybe the second essay you can
see there's a layer of cliche and then
now and then the person will be brave
enough to poke up a thought of their
own.
It'll just sort of poke up somewhere,
maybe in three pages in,
it's like this little green shoot that's
barely alive and the person is brave
enough to pop it up in the hope that you
know,
maybe it won't get wall up down with a
sledge hammer.
And so one of the things I tried to do
is to point that out.
It's like,
look,
you know,
this is something,
there's a real thought here.
It's a real original thought.
It's something that you have the right
to cause.
It's derived from your own experience
and your own knowledge and you
formulated it in an original and
compelling way.
But the problem with that is that if you
get criticized for that,
you're just going to pull right back
into your shell.
Right?
Cause that hurts because it's actually
part of you that you've exposed.
And that's a terrifying thing to expose
yourself like that.
But it's,
it's,
it's an absolute prerequisite to genuine
communication and thought.
So
the ancient Mesopotamians,
I haven't got time to tell you this
story if you want to hear it,
you can come to my maps of meaning class
in your fourth year,
but the most ancient Mesopotamians had
figured out 5,000 years ago or so that
the,
the highest God in the hierarchy of God,
so sorta like the highest value or the
thing that should be imitated most
carefully was a god that whose,
whose head had eyes all the way around
it and who spoke magic words.
And so the words he spoke could make the
sunrise and make the sunset very,
very powerful speaker.
And the reason the Mesopotamians had
figured this out to,
to the degree they had was because they
realized that the capacity to pay
attention,
which is the eyes of course,
because we really pay attention with her
eyes.
And then the capacity to speak
properties,
in fact the highest virtue.
And so then you can check yourself.
You can see all you have to do is
listen.
Like you would listen to someone else
and you have to feel,
you think,
do I actually believe that?
Is that actually my thought?
And really I'll tell you what you'll
find is 95% of what you say has nothing
to do with you.
So it's quite shocking to do this
because you'll start to say something
and you'll think,
oh that doesn't feel quite right.
Like it doesn't make me feel solid when
I say it.
There's something about that that I'm
subordinating myself to something or
hiding in some way.
It's very difficult to figure out
exactly what you're doing,
but you'll find out that
almost everything that's
abstractly represented right,
it has to be that way.
Cause you guys are also young.
So in some sense,
you know way more than you can actually
know,
right?
You've been taught all these things,
but you don't know them.
They're just in your head.
In fact,
they have you rather than the other way
around.
It's like Carl Jung said,
people don't have ideas,
ideas have people.
And that's something to really think
about because then you want to watch and
see what ideas there are floating around
in your head and start to figure out
where they came from because it's highly
probable that they're controlling you.
Just like a Marionette is controlled by
the puppeteer.
It's very,
very similar and there's an
inauthenticity about that.
And so that brings us into
existentialism.
So now I want to talk to you a little
bit about existentialists because
existentialists are very concerned with
authenticity.
And so you could say that above all
else,
existentialists are concerned with
truth.
Now of course we know that it's not very
easy to define exactly what constitutes
truth.
And I would also say there are various
definitions of truth that can be used
for different purposes.
You know,
cause your definitions of truth can also
have a tool,
light function and,
and,
and finally that we can't come up with
an ultimate definition of truth because
we're not infinitely informed,
right?
So ignorance is going to underlie our
claims all the time,
but that doesn't eradicate the validity
of the concept of truth.
And I think one of the ways you can deal
with that existentially is that you may
not be able to determine what's true at
any given moment,
but it's quite a different matter to
determine what's false.
That's a lot easier.
So one of the things I often tell my
clients,
for example,
is,
uh,
here,
here's the way to clean up your life.
Stop doing the things that you know are
wrong that you could stop doing.
Right?
So it's,
it's a fairly,
it's a fairly limited attempt.
First of all,
we're not going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense.
But we will presume that there are
things that you're doing that for one
reason or another,
you know,
are not in your best interests.
There's something about them that you
just know you should stop.
There are kind of self evident to you.
Other things you're going to be doubtful
of it about.
You're not going to know which way is up
in which way is down.
But there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do.
Now,
some of those you won't stop doing for
whatever reason.
You don't have the discipline.
Or maybe there's a secondary pay off.
You don't believe it's necessary or it's
too much of a sacrifice or you're angry
or resentful or or afraid,
who knows?
So forget about those for now.
But there's another subset that you
could stop doing.
It might be little thing.
Well that's fine.
Stop doing it and see what happens.
And what will happen is your vision will
clear a little bit and then something
else will pop up in your field of
apprehension that you will also know you
should stop doing and that you could
stop doing because you strengthened
yourself a bit by stopping doing the
particular stupid thing that you were
doing before that just puts you together
a little bit more.
And you could do that repeatedly for,
for an indefinite period of time.
And,
and you know,
that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear and final picture of
what constitutes the truth and the good.
But it does mean that you'll be able to
continually move away from what's
untruth.
And what's bad and you know,
well,
that's not a bad start.
Now.
Soldier,
an incident who will talk a lot about in
the next lecture,
Solzhenitsyn was a great Russian writer.
He wrote a book called the Gulag
archipelago,
which was instrumental in bringing down
the Soviet Union and Solzhenitsyn,
like Viktor Frankl,
who you'll also read,
was very much convinced that the reason,
the horrors of the Soviet Union and of
the,
of Nazi Germany and of Mao's China and
various other places around the world,
he was very convinced that the reason
those horrors took place,
the death and torture of hundreds of
millions of people was because the
individuals that made up that those
societies were inauthentic in their own
use of of thought and speech.
And so it isn't a following orders
theory.
It's not that at all.
It's a bottom up pathology theory.
It's the reason the whole state is
pathological is because the individuals
that compose it are pathological,
not because they're good and following
orders.
So
I believe that.
I believe that to be the case.
I do believe that the catastrophes of
the state are a consequence of the
amalgamated pathologies of the
individuals,
especially they're willful blindness.
And so another thing that you might
think about,
because most young people do think about
this,
is what is it that you can do in order
to
aid the world?
Let's say like you might if you were
thinking about being an
environmentalist.
Oh,
as far as I can tell,
the one sure.
Route to aiding the world is to clean up
your existential space.
First of all,
you're not telling anyone else what to
do.
That's a big plus and second.
Well,
the more you do that,
the more you're going to be able to do
things,
you know?
And so you might think,
well,
if you're going to clean up the world,
you might start by cleaning up your
phenomenal logical space and see how far
you get with that.
It's a difficult thing to do,
but if you do it,
the better you get at it,
the more capable you are of of handling
larger and larger problems.
And that's how you should start.
You should start with what's right in
your grasp and with what you can control
and not,
that'll enables you to practice.
Now.
And here's the,
here's an offshoot of this.
This is an existential offshoot.
So here's a hypothesis.
So you imagine the existentialists
continually claim,
unlike the psychoanalysts that people
are psychopathological not because say
of childhood trauma or neurosis or
repression or,
or,
uh,
failure to integrate elements of the Ed
into the ego.
They existentialist claim that the
reason that people are
psychopathological is because the
conditions of existence are so tragic
that it's inevitable that people become
psychopathological.
Right?
And that's okay.
So what's the argument?
Well,
people are self conscious,
so that's a big problem.
So,
and because we're self conscious,
we know that we're going to die.
We're aware of our temporal limitations.
So that's our real catastrophe because
no other animal has that problem.
Like elephants looked like they've got
kind of a dim apprehension of it,
but they're not articulate.
So they can't really get to the final
stage of,
you know,
assessing their existence in
relationship to its,
its finitude.
And of course everyone knows that
they're prone to illness of all sorts
and aging and that,
you know,
so is everyone else they know and that
you can be damaged in comprehensively by
untruth and by false hood and bye bye
betrayal.
You know?
And then,
and also that there's 150 things wrong
with you that you're acutely aware of at
almost all times.
So you,
you fall short of perfection along
pretty much any access of comparison
that you wish to generate.
And so the existential point of view on
that is that all of that's enough to
make the default condition of human
beings.
Psychopathological.
It's like the weight of existence itself
is sufficient to make normal
pathological.
And,
and it's a very powerful,
it's very powerful argument.
Cause one of the things you might ask,
and it's certainly something I've asked
when I've dealt with people who have ag
or a phobia for example,
who are afraid to go out.
You know,
they're afraid to go up because they
might have a heart attack and then that
there'll be too far away from the
hospital and then they'll die.
Well,
they make fools of themselves.
That's basically the agoraphobic
spheres.
So it's biological mortality plus social
exposure,
right?
It's bad enough to die,
but if you die in public while
everyone's looking at you,
then you know,
you get the worst of both worlds.
And it is,
to me,
it's not such a mystery that people are
agoraphobic.
It's a mystery that other people aren't,
you know?
And,
and from the existential point of view,
the mystery starts to become the,
the ubiquity of normality given the
intolerable conditions of existence.
It's a much more powerful viewpoint.
And I think it's correct to,
because there's no reason to assume that
the default condition of mankind is like
calm,
rational acceptance of fate.
It's like you have to very,
very specific conditions that you're in
before you're calm and,
and,
you know,
feeling comfortable and sort of hopeful
about the future.
It's like that's a rare state to
achieve.
We can assume that's normal,
at least to some degree in our society
because it's unbelievably
technologically sophisticated and we're
not hungry that often.
We're not cold that often,
or you know,
or even sick that often.
But to think of that is the norm.
It's like,
no,
definitely not.
That's it's a miracle that it's ever
like that.
Now the other claim the existentialists
make fundamentally is something like
this.
It's like,
well,
if the fundamental conditions of
existence are tragic at at minimum,
because there's worse,
there's evil too,
which is different than tragedy because
evil is sort of like unnecessary
tragedy,
you know,
cause there's earthquake say,
who are you going to blame about that?
But then there's you going to school and
you know there's four people who've got
it out for you and all they do is pound
you flat.
Every time you,
you enter the building or make fun of
you and you know,
try to torture you to death.
That's,
that's not tragedy.
it's not accident.
It's not your accidental subjugation to
fate.
It's some horror show perpetrated on you
by people whose only goal is to make
sure that there's more suffering in the
world rather than less.
So you also have to put up with that.
But we'll leave that aside for the time
being.
You're stuck in your pathology because
of the conditions of existence are
intolerable to a self conscious being.
We'll say that.
So then you might ask,
well what could you do about that?
Well,
here's one potential answer.
Not Answer is see what happens if you
stop doing things you know to be
inadequate and wrong.
So the hypothesis is every time you
engage in an activity like that,
you weaken yourself,
you put yourself down first,
you remove your own self confidence,
but you also fail to take the
opportunity to expand your domain of
competence.
What would life be like if you didn't do
that?
And the existential claim is it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weak claim in some ways.
The claim is bots.
There's two.
One is,
if you don't do that,
if you don't try to fix the things that
you could fix,
things will go from bad to worse for
your life.
And that will spread out and it will
take everyone else's life along with it.
So that,
so that's on the negative end.
So you don't do it because of the
negative end.
But then there's a positive claim to
which is maybe if you stopped bullying
yourself,
the tragic conditions of existence would
become because you would be strong
enough to tolerate them.
And,
and it's,
it's analogous to use idea of
progression towards the self because
young has a very strong,
is existential theme underlying his work
derived mostly from nature.
But it's,
it's the most optimistic.
It's the only optimistic hypothesis I've
ever seen in psychology.
Truly optimistic hypothesis because
there's other hypotheses like the
positive illusions hypothesis,
which is basically life is so tragic
that you have to tell yourself,
you know,
happy false hoods just so you don't go
insane.
And that's what normal people do,
which I think is an absolutely appalling
philosophy.
It's,
it's,
it's the ultimate and cynicism that,
but still there,
you know,
there's a huge literature on the
supposedly utility of positive
illusions.
And then there's also the associated
sort of terror management hypothesis,
which is that the purpose of your belief
systems is to protect you from the
anxiety of death,
which has sort of a variant of the
Friday and idea that religion was a
childish delusion designed to protect
people from terror of their own
mortality.
Very powerful critique of religion,
although it's one that I happen to think
is wrong.
I mean one of the problems with Freud's
formulation is that it fails to deal
with,
you know,
concepts like the underworld and hell.
I mean,
if you're going to just whip up a belief
system to protect yourself against the
fear of death,
why in the world would you envision
something like an eternity of suffering
worse than death?
If you ever step out of line,
it's very hard to understand how that's
a defense mechanism.
Now,
a cynic would say,
well,
the only reason that say Christians
invented hell,
even though they didn't,
it's a very old idea,
is so that they had somewhere convenient
to put people who didn't agree with
them.
But you have to be unbelievably cynical
to assume that that's the only reason I,
I don't think there's any historical
support for the idea that that's the
only reason.
Now I'm going to tell you some,
I'm going to tell you some stories that
some of the most famous existentialists
and history told their their ideas and
quotations and,
and I,
the existentialists that I've read are
often the most powerful of writers.
So Dostoyevsky's an existentialist and
Solzhenitsyn and says an existentialist.
And so as Viktor Frankl who survived the
concentration camps and Kierkegaard,
very weird collection of people,
I mean they're,
they're fundamental belief systems were
often very much at odds with one
another.
Some of them are atheists and some of
them are Orthodox Christians especially,
uh,
you know,
cause a lot of the literary
existentialists were Russian.
So you can come at existentialism from a
variety of origin points.
But what they have in common is what I
kind of outlined is that the first idea
is the essential preconditions of life
are sufficiently tragic to render the
normative state of humanity,
pathological and,
and health something as something and
health and wholeness is something very
difficult to,
to uh,
aspire to or accomplish.
And that and that the road to that
health is the reduction of deceit.
And so that's a thing that's also very
interesting about the existentialist
cause they make a very
straightforward moral claim,
which is that lies make people sick.
And I'll,
I'll tell you in my experience as a
psychotherapist,
I mean,
you know,
I can tell you some of the things that
make people sick,
a lot of them have nothing to do with
the psyche.
The things that make people sick,
car while they get unemployed.
It's like unemployment just lays people
out,
especially if they're conscientious and
they just devour themselves.
And it's so stressful,
right?
Cause if you're unemployed,
well your finances become shaky almost
right away.
Plus you don't have any routine.
Plus you're not involved in anything
meaningful in relationship to society.
You know?
And then you start to eat yourself up
with doubts and,
and,
uh,
you know,
self criticism,
especially if you're a conscientious
person or especially if you're a
conscientious person who's high in
negative emotion.
It's like unemployment will just flatten
you and then the death or illness of
yourself or close relative,
that's really hard on people.
And uh,
there and there were situations at work
that are difficult so people are
bullied.
Maybe they have a terrible supervisor or
they're,
or they're in a pathological social
structure so that,
you know,
they're basically being bullied and
oppressed with every step they take or
they're in a very horrendous
relationship.
But,
but then things start to turn a bit.
So,
okay,
so you can lose your job and you can be
ill or dying and so can people around
you.
And that'll lay low on a lot of the time
and no wonder,
right?
It's logical.
And when,
when people come to me with those sorts
of problems,
the first thing I often notice,
they're not psychological.
I tell the people that that's not a
psychological problem.
You're unemployed.
That's an actual problem.
And it's really useful to distinguish
those.
Right?
So,
so for example,
and this is something that psychiatric
diagnosis does it very,
very badly.
If someone comes to me and they're
depressed so they're not sleeping
properly,
they feel terrible in the morning,
you know,
they,
they don't have a lot of energy.
They're having a hard time experiencing
any positive emotion.
It's difficult for them to move.
Um,
and they have a lot of negative thoughts
about the past and the present and the
future.
I do an analysis of their life first to
say,
well,
you know,
you have a job that's,
all right that,
you know,
that did at least isn't horrifying.
You know,
is it okay for you to go to work in the
morning?
Do you have an intimate relationship
that's basically functional d,
do you have some friends you know,
um,
are your relationships with your family
members?
Okay?
Are you reasonably healthy apart,
apart from the depression?
And do you have useful and interesting
things to do that aren't related to your
career?
And if the person says yes to all of
those and they're still feeling
terrible,
then I think,
okay,
this person is depressed.
Right?
Because they don't have a problem.
They're just depressed.
And in my experience,
those are the people who respond quite
well to antidepressants.
You know,
cause their nervous system isn't
calibrating.
It's an analysis of their situation to
the reality of the situation.
It's as if they're lower status
according to their status.
Comparitor which is a very primordial
thing since even lobsters have it,
it's their status.
Comparitor isn't paying attention to
their actual status.
And maybe that's because they're,
you know,
temperamentally high in negative
emotion.
Or maybe it's because they had been
traumatized earlier in their life.
And so they're much more sensitive to
any signs of failure.
It's easy to,
it's easier to knock them down.
But then you have the other people who
are,
well,
they don't have a job and they ha they
never have.
And maybe they're 30 or 35 no real
stable employment history,
no real educational history.
It's pretty patchy.
One or more illnesses.
And then family members who are just out
for there,
absolute destruction,
like families can be unbelievably
pathological.
So they're in meshed in the familial
situation where for one reason or
another,
as soon as they get up off the ground a
little bit,
someone knocks them back down and so,
and then maybe they have a drug or
alcohol problem to go along with that.
Or they have a relationship with someone
who has a drug and alcohol problem or a
mental illness and sometimes you see
people who have like all five of those
things going on at the same time.
It's like
that's not precisely mental illness.
Now a lot of that's associated with
deceit,
you know,
they're entangled in relationships and
in relationships with themselves that
are pathologically untrue.
So I've seen people,
for example,
who
I've seen people who are in families
where probably nothing they were ever
told was true.
Like it was never just true.
It was always twisted and bent in some
way by whoever was talking to them.
For the purposes of that person power or
domination or or positive illusion or
delusion or something like all the
communication within the family was
motivated.
And so there,
it's so awful to grow up in an
environment like that because you can't
get a grip on what's real.
And then you know,
it can get worse than that in that the
person will tell you that they love you
and they'll act all sweet,
but every time you do anything that's
even vaguely productive and useful,
they'll just criticize you to death and
all the wild telling you that they love
you.
It's really horrible.
And that's all tangled up with deception
and lies.
And it's a weird thing because if you
look at the Freudian hypotheses,
you'll notice that Freud attributed an
awful lot of psychopathology to
repression,
right?
But I think the distinction between
repression and self deception or deceit
is very permeable.
It's like what's the difference between
repressing something and lying to
yourself about it?
Well,
Freud would say often that repression
occurs unconsciously,
but I really wonder about that.
I think that what happens is that
something happened or you did something
that you don't like and it's bothering
you and you could think it through,
but you just decide not to.
You just don't think it through.
So it's left vague and uncertain and you
know,
fairly emotionally salient,
but you just refuse to think it through.
And you practice doing that until you've
built up a habit of not thinking that
through.
And then you forget that you've built up
the habit.
And then it's like,
it's being repressed unconsciously.
But I think that,
you know,
or at least you knew when you first did
it.
And so you know,
when you meet people who are acting in a
twisted in peculiar way,
and you ask yourself,
they're very manipulative.
Say you ask yourself,
well do they know what they're doing?
The answer to that could be,
well,
no,
but another answer could be,
yeah,
but they knew once,
they knew,
when they made the decision to start
acting like that,
but after they did it a hundred times or
so and made it into an automatic
routine,
well then they forgot its origin.
And now it runs autonomously.
And so now they don't know.
But they did know.
And so you know,
this is the sort of point and this is
the real point of the existentialists
were
clinical psychology and,
and the claims of morality start to
become very tightly aligned.
And it's something that the psychiatric
and psychological industries,
so to speak,
don't really tackle head on.
My experience has been that in these
situations,
for example,
where the person has five terrible
things going on in their life that
there's just deception twisted in and
strewn in,
all of that.
People are betraying each other.
There's no fidelity in the
relationships.
There's no clear and genuine
communication.
Everything's manipulation.
No one admits to what they're really up
to.
You know,
there's a lot of false and Saccharin
love,
which has absolutely nothing to do with
love.
It's all for appearance,
you know,
and you cannot be healthy in a situation
like that.
I don't think in my experience,
you know,
apart from terrible luck cause you know,
you can get cancer,
diabetes or any number of awful things.
In my experience,
apart from the tragedies of life,
there is nothing that hurts people more
than deception,
lies do people in,
and that's an existentialist claim.
The claim is first,
while life is basically unbearable.
That's an existential claim.
And then there's,
there's the hope that with sufficient
caution and attention and clarity of
thought and speech,
you can match.
You can it,
you can,
you can master it to the point where you
could even accept the fact that it's
tragic.
But if you multiply,
it's tragedy with the use of deceit.
It's like,
forget it because you know,
it's one thing to be hurt,
you know,
maybe you break your leg.
That's one thing.
It's another thing to be attacked by two
or three people who break your leg and
do everything they can to demean you at
the same time.
It's like lots of people break their leg
and they're not traumatized.
It's very few people who can go through
the ladder experience without being,
you know,
seriously and permanently damaged.
Here's Pascal,
one of the first existentialists when I
considered the brief span of my life,
swallowed up in the eternity before and
behind it,
the small space that I feel or even see
engulfed in the infinite immensity of
spaces,
which I know not and which,
no,
not me.
I am afraid and I wonder to see myself
here rather than there for,
there's no reason why I should be here
rather than there or now rather than
then.
Now another thing the existentialists do
that's,
that's very,
and they're Romantics,
they're not enlightenment rationalist.
And part of the reason they're romantics
is because they actually don't believe
that life is rational.
And Pascal's comment on on what what the
existentialists often called thrownness
is a description of the fundamental
irrationality of life.
It's like,
okay,
here you are.
Well,
why you?
Why here?
Why now?
Why the way you look,
why with your family,
why you're gender?
Well,
there's no answer to any of those
questions.
It's just
how it is.
It's blind and random chance.
Maybe there's this,
but even if it's not that there's
something arbitrary about,
and there's something that's arbitrary
and not self evidently just or fair,
you know,
cause maybe you could've been born,
there are people around the world who
make their living in garbage heaps,
right?
So there's whole families and whole
societies that live out in the garbage
dumps and all they do is pick out,
you know,
the,
the metal and glass that will enable
them to sort of glean out of living.
It's like,
well,
why the hell aren't you born there
instead of,
you know,
sitting right here.
So there's an irrational element to
that.
Right?
You can't justify it.
You can't explain it and you don't
really even know what to do about it.
Right.
I mean,
do you owe an existential debt to the
people who were born much worse off than
you?
Or is it just okay that it's that way?
Well,
it's a problem that that by the way,
is the problem,
the existentialists called thrownness,
which is you're arbitrarily here in that
form and there's no explanation for it
and it,
it's something that's outside of human
concepts of say justice and equity and
fairness and,
and even sensibility.
And then Pascal also points to the fact
that,
well,
we're localized things.
You know,
you're right there and there's a lot of
what isn't right there around you.
So you're a small thing against a big
infinitely large potential span of
experience.
And that's also an existential
challenge.
It's the challenge of the finite against
the,
the infinite.
And that's also an existential problem,
which is that it isn't your problem or
it is,
it's more ad problem.
It's just a problem that springs out of
being human.
One of the places where existentialism
and phenomenology touch
the phenomenologists of course,
make the case that reality is best
conceived of as the totality of your
experience,
even if that includes things that you
wouldn't normally consider you.
But certainly it includes things like
emotions and motivations and bodily
sensations and all the things that
aren't precisely rational.
The existentialists would take that
claim and push it a bit farther by
saying,
and this is analogous to something I
already told you,
that
the degree to which that
phenomenological field,
your field of experience is fractured
and incoherent and paradoxical,
that that that occurs in pr,
precise proportion to the week to the
weakening of the spirit within you that
necessarily has to be strong in order to
remain on corrupted by the tragic
conditions of existence.
So along with the existentialist claim,
which is that life is unbearable and
it's in its very nature,
it's tragic and unbearable in its very
nature is the idea that that's made
worse by your own set of inadequacies,
inadequacies that you could repair and
worse that to the degree that you are
rife with inadequacies that you could
repair,
you're going to make the tragic
situation that's integral to life worse
again,
not only for yourself but also for other
people.
So out of existentialism also
automatically arises a kind of moral
necessity,
which is that you can't just sit in
isolation and be useless and resentful.
That doesn't work.
If you're useless and resentful and you
refuse to address the things that you
know you should address,
you can't help but pathologize
everything around you,
and so you're stuck with a moral duty.
And the existentialists would would say
more than that.
They would say,
if you don't
shoulder that existential burden,
that existential moral burden,
you will inevitably suffer for it.
You cannot get out of it.
You're stuck with it.
So the existentialists are great
believers in freewill in that you have
choice,
but the wheel has parameters,
right?
There are still things that you can't
get away with,
and one of them is
you can't.
You fundamentally can't get away with
being immoral.
The structure of existence is set up
well.
One of the things you might say if you
were thinking about it existentially is
immoral things are precisely those
things that you can't get away with.
That's why people have identified them
as immoral is that they will inevitably,
the consequences of enacting will
inevitably be brought to bear on you or
on the people you love for.
They'll,
it'll snap back in some way.
You know,
and I see this in psychotherapy very
often too,
people will engage in the same kind of
behavior over and over.
Well,
there's a classic definition of
insanity,
which is insanity is doing the same
thing over and over and expecting a
different outcome each time.
And there's an element of self deception
in that.
Like people will
run out a procedure that ends in tragedy
and then they'll repeat that over and
over and you can lay out for them the
causal connection between their actions
and their conceptions and outcome.
And they'll listen,
but there's no change whatsoever and
behavior.
And so then they run through the routine
again and bang.
And what they're doing is immoral
precisely because whenever they
implemented it produces the kind of
catastrophe they claim to want to avoid
it.
Because you know,
relativists martyred relativists like to
think of virality as something that's
just the arbitrary,
like it's a cultural construction.
You know,
and society one thinks that a is bad and
society to thinks that B is bad.
And when you get right down to it,
there's no commonality underneath all
that.
But the existentialists sort of undercut
all that and they just say,
well,
what's immoral?
Or those things that you could change
that you do that result in outcomes that
are catastrophic for you.
That's it.
That's what immoral is.
And so that's universal because it
doesn't really matter what the details
are,
you know,
like what you do that's immoral could be
very much different than what you do.
It might be temperamental,
you know,
we're each in our own playing field in a
sense.
But there's a commonality underneath
that,
which is,
well for example,
you won't get away with deceiving
yourself.
You just can't.
And the reason you can't is because you
need a model of the world.
It's like the world.
And if you try to live in a model of the
world,
it isn't like the world,
you'll just bump into the world.
And so the the deception brings with it
its own punishment and that's why it's
immoral.
There's other elements of existentialism
that I think are extremely interesting.
For example,
the definition of Truth and
existentialism is,
is different than the definition of
truth that might be characteristic of
objective materialism.
So truths that are truths from the
perspective of objective materialism are
scientific truths and they're usually
descriptive truths.
And so the truth claims of science go
something like this all undertake a
procedure,
which I'll tell you about and I'll
observe the outcomes.
And then if you undertake that procedure
and you observe the outcomes and
outcomes are the same,
you know,
and we'll do this maybe a hundred times
just to be certain,
then we'll assume that what that outcome
is is real.
So it's a definition of a procedure
that's,
that's the experiment that elicits the
outcome and then the demonstration that
the outcome is constant across
observers.
So that's a lovely definition of truth.
And it obviously has extreme utility,
partly because it helps you separate
subjective fantasy,
which is a form of reality from other
forms of realities.
So another form of reality would be
collectively apprehensible reality.
You don't want to confuse those two
things.
In fact,
that's actually a sign of if not not
naivety and a state of undeveloped
differentiation.
It can also be a sign of insanity
because one of the things say that
characterizes schizophrenia,
this,
they can't tell the difference between
what only they experience and what
everybody else experiences.
So the scientific definition of truth is
a perfectly reasonable definition,
but it's not the existential definition
of truth.
The existential definition of truth is
more action predicated.
So for the existentialists truth is a
way of being,
it's not a collection of descriptions.
So it's more,
it's more embodied,
you know,
from the PSG and point of view.
And so truth is reflected in,
in what you act.
So neat.
You would say for example,
it doesn't matter what you say,
it matters what you do.
And if I want to figure out what you
believe,
I don't ask you,
I watch how you act.
And I assume that your true beliefs are
those that are directing your actions.
And so truth is discovered in action.
And that's a very different claim.
You know,
and it,
it's,
it's not the claim of a passive
observer.
It's the claim of someone who's actively
interacting with the world.
And of course we are always acting.
We're always acting interactively with
the world.
And not only that,
if we don't act interactively with the
world,
we cease to exist.
So we have to do that merely to maintain
ourselves.
And so the existential claim would be
given that in our essential nature,
there are ways that you can act that are
in your improper Ndu.
Technically it's like for example,
let's say you want a,
and then you act in a bunch of ways that
makes it absolutely impossible that you
will get a,
it's like an existentialist would say,
well there's something wrong with that
Schema.
Like it's a,
it's,
it's not necessarily a moral because
that would only be if you were willfully
blind to it.
But they would certainly say,
well,
it's got this self contradictory element
that makes it wrong.
So,
so in so far it's like this in so far as
you're acting,
you're acting towards the name,
you want something and then in so far as
you want something,
the fact that you want,
it constitutes the framework within
which you evaluate the utility and truth
of your actions.
Right?
So it's like you come up with a theory
of truth just because you're doing
something and the theory is a that what
you want is acceptable to want and you
know that can be true or not,
but it doesn't matter.
You just assume that and be that
those things that will get you to that
and are appropriate.
You can't get out of that.
If you're doing something,
you're making a claim about the
structure of the world and what
constitutes appropriate action.
As soon as you make any action,
you can't get out of that.
Okay.
Nisha said,
can one live it all truths are bloody
truths to me and then that's an issue.
That's one of the things I really like
about reading the existentialists too.
It's not,
there's no,
there's no abstract disembodiment in
their philosophy.
You see that the people who are writing
as existentialists are committed to what
they say they want to.
They want to enact what they say in the
world.
It's,
and it's romantic because it does
involve emotions and motivation.
It see with reasoning alone,
enlightenment view of reason was that
reason and the passions were
antagonistic,
that all the passions could do would be
to cloud reason and that it was reasons
job to lift itself up above the body and
the emotions and clarified the nature of
the world.
He,
the existentialists would deny that
completely.
They would say,
no,
no.
It's that the purpose,
the appropriate mode of being is to act
properly.
And rationality can be a guide to that,
but can also,
it can also deceive and all sorts of
ways.
The passions inform you.
They don't cloud your reasoning,
although of course they can because they
tend to be kind of single minded.
You know,
they can take you off course,
but that doesn't mean that they're
enemies of rational clarity per se.
And when the existentialists right,
you can tell they put their whole being
into it.
So it's,
it's,
it's gripping and passionate.
The existentialists.
I've also identified sort of classes of
pathology that are unique in some ways.
They are outside the purview of standard
psychology and psychiatry.
So,
okay.
You,
you see often if you're looking at
debate,
say between atheists and religious
people,
one of the things that tends to set the
atheist back on their heels is the
observation that the religious people
make that if there's no final meaning to
anything,
then there's no meaning to anything.
And so that it immediately elicits,
it's a kind of nihilism.
It's like if nothing means anything,
why do anything?
And it's a reasonable argument because
doing things requires effort and you can
say to yourself,
well,
why should I do x or y?
Especially if x is difficult.
If who the hell's going to know when the
thousand years are,
who the hell is going to know where in a
hundred years or why does it matter
anyways?
And then the atheist,
so tie themselves up in knots trying to
address that issue.
But the existentialists take a different
perspective.
Nisha said,
for example,
he was,
he viewed the emergence of nihilism as a
kind of cultural pathology.
And so you remember of course that it
was Nietzsche who said God is dead,
right?
You see that scrolled out in like
washroom graffiti from time to time.
You know,
it's,
it's like a truism,
but that isn't what Nisha said.
He said,
God is dead and we have killed him and
we'll never find enough water to wash
away the blood,
which is a very,
very different statement.
It wasn't like he was proclaiming it
triumphantly.
It was more like a catastrophic loss of
meaning,
you know,
the sort of loss of meaning that the
terror management theorists would say
would produce like a traumatic
pathology.
Now what needs you observed was that
there,
you know,
and of course you all know this to some
degree,
that in the course of the development of
scientific knowledge and rationality,
that a contradiction between our
historical moral knowledge formulated
and religious terms and our descriptive
rational knowledge emerged conflict
between science and religion.
Now,
part of that conflict is a losery
because the purpose of religion is to
tell you how to act and the purpose of
science is to provide clear descriptions
of of what universally apprehensible
reality.
They're not working in precisely the
same domains.
It doesn't matter niches.
Observation was this,
he said,
well,
it's pretty clear that the scientific
lists are going to demolish the
substructure of Western religious belief
and then of course the substructure of
that sort of belief all the way around
the world and there's going to be
consequences to that.
And he said,
there's going to be two consequences,
and he predicted this say an 1850 it's
something like 1850 and will to power.
It's unbelievable.
He said that what's going to happen in
Europe is that there'll be the rise of
socialist slash communist Utopian that
will possess people and that will
produce a war and the consequence of
that war,
that will be that hundreds of millions
of people die.
And he predicted that like 80 years
before it happened.
Well,
maybe less.
If you think of the Russian revolution
as a precursor of that,
which Dostoyevsky would've certainly
viewed it as a precursor of that now.
So there's totalitarianism on one side
that's,
that's one of the dangers
and other danger is nihilism.
And then now nihilism emerges because
you shatter the meaning structure within
which action is conceptualized.
And so those are like two emergent
pathologies that threatened people.
Now if you talk to someone who's
nihilistic and rationalist or almost
always nihilistic,
especially if they're depressed,
they'll say things like,
like I already told you,
what difference does it make anyways?
Now Dostoyevsky played out those themes,
for example,
in in a really very,
very powerful way and a number of his
books.
So the possessed,
for example,
it's funny cause Dostoyevsky and Nichi
road at the same time,
and Dostoevsky wrote literature,
Nature Road Philosophy,
but they were doing exactly the same
thing in Dostoyevsky's the possessed,
he talked about description of the
Russian political economic ideological
scene.
And what he saw happening was that as
people moved away from there in
measurement,
in a historically condition meaning
system,
so that was say Judeo Christianity,
that they started to become susceptible
to utopian rationalist utopian
ideologies.
It was so out with one belief system in
with another and the other was more
dangerous because like the religious
system sort of emerged from the bottom
up and they were weird and mythical and
difficult to understand from a
rationalist perspective.
Whereas the Utopian schemes were
rational constructions in theology is
very narrow and they're just imposed on
people.
So for the example of the communists
would say from each according to his
ability to each according to his need,
which sounds wonderful,
but if you put it into practice,
it's like it's instantly genocidal.
So Nisha said,
well,
as
the modern world suffers through the
contradiction between scientific
rationality and
ritual religion,
historically conditioned,
the consequence of that is going to be
that two pathologies will emerge.
One is reliance on totalitarianism.
And so I would say to the degree that
any of you are any logical,
then you've succumb to the one pole of
of post religious pathology and all
you've done is replace adherence to one
set of beliefs.
Even though religious beliefs are not
precisely beliefs with another,
it's rationally constructed and
incredibly dangerous.
And he said,
well,
if it isn't going to be totalitarianism,
it's going to be nihilism.
But the thing that's so interesting
about the existentialist does they make
a forthright claim that regardless of
whether or not the fact that people will
turn to those alternatives is a rational
can be rationalized.
It makes sense that it would happen.
It's still pathological.
It's like it,
it's a,
it's like an a priori statement.
So I could say,
well,
let's say you're nihilistic.
You know,
you,
you lack,
you have a lot of doubt about life's
meaning and purpose and it's like it's
eating at you.
It's,
it's,
it's a disease of the soul.
And you'll come to me and you tell me 30
logical reasons why what you say has to
be true.
And I would say those are excellent
logical reasons.
And you're making a very powerful
argument,
but it doesn't matter.
It's irrelevant.
The fact that you're nihilistic means
that you're infected with a pathology
and whether or not you can justify it
rationally is completely irrelevant.
All it means is that your rational mind
is capable of spinning off a sequence of
logical tricks.
And the ultimate truth is it's
undermining your ability live.
And so it's wrong.
Why is it wrong?
I don't care why it's wrong.
It's not relevant.
Why it's wrong.
What's relevant is you can't live like
that.
And that's an existential claim cause
the existentialists are interested in
different kinds of truth.
They would say that a truth you cannot
live is not true because their
definition of truth is different.
It's predicated on action.
And then the totalitarianism claim is
the same thing.
So let's say that you're an ardent right
winger,
or you're an ardent socialist,
or you're an ardent feminist or an
environmentalist,
or who cares what the ISM is.
You've abstracted out a bunch of axioms.
You develop a coherent representation of
the world and it's pathological.
It doesn't matter what the content is.
It's pathological because it's not you.
It's not you.
If it was you,
then a million other people wouldn't
believe it.
So the existentialists would say if a
million other people believe it,
it's definitely false.
And they're not talking about scientific
claims.
That's a whole different,
that's a whole different order of,
of discussion and description.
They're clearly making the point that
you're an individual thing and if you've
been unable to particularize your
experience and you've replaced that with
adherence to some sort of arbitrary and
universal call to action or
representation,
you've your pathological,
it's a form of mental illness.
And you might say,
well what's the evidence for that?
Well,
what we'll find out in the next lecture
is the 20th century was evidence for
that.
Not so much for the nihilism nihilism
aspect.
I think that we're still in for that
cause I think we swung to
totalitarianism first and that didn't
work.
And so now you see this in postmodernism
for example,
it's an unbelievably nihilistic
philosophy because it claims that all
meaning for example,
is reduceable to motivations of power,
which is like intellect,
intellectually simplistic beyond belief.
And it comes straight out of like 1950s
Marxism and you know it's,
it's,
it's pretty much permeated the
humanities and the study of literature,
universities all over North America.
It's,
it's,
it's sick beyond belief to teach young
people that all meaning is relative.
It's the last thing you guys need to
hear when you're like 20 it's,
and the reason that people teach it is
because there are more afraid that
things might have meaning then they are
afraid that things might not cause you
might ask yourself,
well,
here's two options.
One is it doesn't bloody.
Won't matter what you do.
Who the hell cares?
Who's going to know in a thousand years?
And everything's relative.
While you think,
God,
nothing could be worse than that.
Well,
I can tell you something that would be
worse than that.
It's easy.
Let's take the reverse.
Everything you do matters.
Okay,
so what's the downside of that?
It's like you don't get to get away with
anything.
Everything you do is important.
It's linked to everything else.
It's like,
okay,
now choose.
You got a choice.
You can either choose to believe
nihilistic Lee,
that nothing has any meaning.
Well,
you get to be depressed and anxious and
it may be you're impulsive cause that's
the only kind of pleasure you can find.
But the advantage is you don't have any
responsibility.
You can do whatever you want and then a
psychoanalyst would say,
hm,
maybe that's why you believe it.
That's a secondary gain,
right?
You think you believe it cause you've
derived it logically.
It's like,
yeah,
sure.
No,
no,
you believe it because it's in the best
interest of the worst aspects of you to
believe it because it,
it justifies sloths and cynicism.
While the opposite is,
yeah,
what you do matters.
It's like,
well,
why not believe that?
We'll try believing it's seriously and
see what happens.
You take the existential claim
seriously.
One of them is you make a mistake,
especially one that you know is a
mistake.
You will absolutely pay for it and worse
that you'll never get away with it.
And worse than that,
it'll domino out into the world.
So not only will you pay for it,
but the people that you're connected
with will pay for it.
There's always a price.
It's like,
well,
you decide which of those two things is
more terrifying.
You know,
when you read Freud and Freud says
religion is a defense against death,
anxiety.
Well,
that's a good argument,
but it is not by no means clear to me at
all.
That the reverse of that,
which is the idea that things have
intrinsic meaning and that you have a
unlike an intrinsic responsibility.
It's by no means clear to me that that's
a comforting idea.
It could easily be that the more
comforting ideas that you know,
you're just a Spec in a collection of
specs and what you do doesn't matter.
Well,
you can sit and play video games for the
rest of your life and it isn't gonna
make any difference.
It doesn't have any significance.
Well,
if the opposite is true,
you know,
every time you do something
pathological,
especially if you know it's
you tilt the whole world towards
pathology.
And so the existentialists would say of
the 20th century,
we just about an isolated ourselves once
in 1962 and then once again in the early
eighties were this far away from nuclear
annihilation.
You might ask yourself,
well,
why didn't we do it?
And the existential answer would be as a
collective human beings decided that it
would be better to continue being than
not to.
And the way they decided that was by
shifting the ratio of their pathological
to honest behaviors a little bit more
towards honesty.
And you know,
you might wonder about this sort of
thing if this kind of thing could
possibly be true.
Well that's why I have you read Frankel
and soldier Nitsa,
you know,
they're not classic personality
theorists,
but it doesn't matter to me because
they're getting at something that's
deeper than the terror management
theorists are the people who deal with
positive illusions.
They're trying to make a case based on
the analysis of an entire bloody
century.
And the case is society's become
carnivorous and pathological and precise
proportion to the degree that the
individuals who make up that society
become deceitful and irresponsible.
Okay.
And I've never encountered a political
or economic analysis or claim that has
anywhere near the power of that,
but it's a terrifying proposition.
Even though what you get out of it is
while your life is meaningful,
your life is meaningful,
and then if all of a sudden you find
that you're suffering unnecessarily.
This is a weird thing too about meaning
claims.
You know someone's Nihilistic,
they come and talk to you.
They say,
well,
my life has any,
there's no meaning in my life.
And I say,
well,
how do you feel about that?
And they say,
well,
I'm really feeling bad.
And then you say,
well,
that's a meaning.
Feeling bad,
being anxious,
hurting.
Those are meanings.
They're just not very good meanings.
And so then you might also ask yourself
if your philosophy
okay
throws you in the direction of
overwhelming negative emotion,
anxiety and pain,
and that's a meaning.
Hey,
you might note you're not going to argue
yourself out of that.
Okay?
Which shows that there's a meaning
basis.
You can't just all of a sudden decide
you're not hurting,
you're not anxious.
You don't have control over that.
The meaning of your pain is,
is completely impenetrable to your
rational mind.
So even if you're nihilistic,
you have to admit to the of negative
emotion.
Well then what do you do?
You just denied the existence of
anything positive.
Well,
why is that reasonable?
Maybe it's just that,
wow,
you could be unlucky and maybe you're
not.
Well,
you know when maybe you have reasons to
be suffering that have nothing to do
with the way you're construing the
world,
because people do get unlucky.
But there's always the possibility that
the reason that things are so terrible
for you was that you're inhabiting a
pathological perspective.
That's an existential point of view.
And somebody tells me what time it is.
It's one.
Oh,
well good.
Then we can stop.
We'll see you after reading week.